à quelques semaines des vacances de
pâques et deux mois et demi après la
marée noire l'inquiétude des habitants
de belle-ile déterminé à réhabiliter
l'image de marque de ce haut lieu
touristique auprès des vacanciers les
dernières informations concernant la
toxicité des nappes de fioul laisse un
sentiment de découragement
yasmina farber blaise godet
inlassablement ils traquent les
boulettes de fioul qui remonte à la
surface
avec le retour du beau temps une barge
peut enfin sillonné les criques
inaccessibles de belle-ile
il faut éviter que des galettes se
détachent des rochers et viennent salir
des plages déjà nettoyer les sites
pollués
quand les signalent d'ailleurs pour les
marques sur l'a4 non il n'ya dans le
supérieur et la pollution un carrefour
important trou par north beaucoup moins
important pauvre petit à petit les lille
retrouve son charme de cartes postales
3000 tonnes de fuel ramassés en deux
mois et demi beaucoup de travail pour
effacer les traces de la marée noire
depuis le 26 décembre
il ne se passe pas un jour sans une
réunion au pc de crise ce soir là le
président du district ne peut éviter un
sujet sensible nouveaux jets de
particules cancérigènes
chaque responsable est priée de rappeler
des consignes comme l'utilisation des
gants mais déjà des bénévoles annuler
leur séjour sur les 180 prévue lundi
140 ne viendront pas les bellilois
navigue entre compréhension et agacement
le communiqué de toxicité qu'on nous
envoie tous les vendredis soirs ça
commence à suffire ondes et on dirait
qu'il est fait exprès alors que si vous
prenez votre voiture
le l'essence que via dans votre voiture
est aussi cancérigènes
donc ça suffit l'histoire du cancer on
connaît on a entendu on n'est pas fous
militaires pompiers ou salariés de total
ils continuent leur travail de
dépollution la plage de donnant était
totalement soulier aujourd'hui les
surfeurs retrouvent leur lieu de
prédilection
mais la marée noire ne se fait pas
oublier si vite
à
ça reste comme ça
lors des trois journées du major
annonce
les bellilois veulent pourtant rester
optimiste avant la saison touristique
les trois quarts des plages sont
quasiment propre mais tant que le fion
de l'erika n'aura pas été pompés
personne ne se sentira vraiment à l'abri